Todd and Julie Chrisley both heading to
prison in Florida just couple of weeks
into the New Year I pray to God every
day we made a commitment that we were
not going to give up in docks obtained
by E.T the couple's been ordered to
report to prison on January 17th to
begin their combined 19-year sentence
and now we're learning more about what's
to come in the big house we're going to
Florida it's pastel season yeah except
this time Orange Is the New Periwinkle I
mean we're in Florida got a beautiful
house we got a hole the sunshine State's
gonna look a little different this time
we've learned once the Chrisley's
check-in they'll be under minimum
security what we will not do is we will
not break
so where exactly are they heading for
Todd's 12-year sentence the federal
prison camp in Pensacola meanwhile Julie
will be over two hours away serving her
seven-year sentence and Mariana's
Federal Correctional Institution these
were very serious crimes the fraud was
extensive back in June Todd and Julie
were convicted of bank fraud and tax
evasion
sending a message to the community at
large that these crimes are noticed that
these crimes do not go unpunished and
after getting their sentences handed
down last month another legal battle
might be on deck but if you come at my
kids then I'm gonna drag you speaking
out on their Chrisley confessions
podcast the couple insists their adopted
ten-year-old daughter Chloe will remain
in the family Chloe is a very bright
intelligent
charismatic funny beautiful child who
has a heart of compassion
and her life is going to be as unaltered
as it possibly can be based on what Judy
and I have the ability to to control
this comes after Chloe's biological mom
Angela told TMZ last week she plans to
get Chloe back Chloe is actually Todd
and Julie's granddaughter the child of
Todd's son from a previous marriage Kyle
Angela Johnson gave her she literally
surrendered her rights to her child
she did this in front of a judge the
judge explained to her you understand
what you're doing you understand that
you have surrendered the rights and
you're surrendering the rights of your
child and then explained that she had x
amount of days to come back in and
rescind that clearly a lot on the
Chrisley's plate going into the holidays
but when E.T spoke with their daughter
Savannah in the days leading up to their
sentencing she said her parents are
getting through it all by relying
heavily on faith I've never seen two
people my parents be so steadfast in
their face in the end the truth will
prevail may get harder before it gets
easier but we have faith
foreign
[Music]